all right Queen Queen where'd you grow
up where you from I'm born and raised
from Brooklyn New York
I'm from the Bronx tell me about your
childhood you grew up with both of your
parents um I started off yeah but both
of my parents and then my father left
when I was at least 10 years old and
then I ended up losing my mother when I
was 14 how did you lose your heart she
had a seizure at work and collapsed and
never looked back though so she died her
she yeah she died of an all-star team so
since then I was getting passed around a
family family and it just wasn't working
that's a rough childhood and where did
you life go from there did you I end up
having to come out to California when I
was around 15 out there I was getting in
a lot of trouble so after my mom died
like I end up going to juvenile just you
know it's just start getting crazy so my
family out there made me come down here
to my father's side of the family
and I stayed in Oakland California for
at least most of my life from there on
and then I just recently moved out here
to LA so I've been out here for like a
year and a half right now okay and how
was your childhood other than losing
your parents it's been it's been hard I
just say that um well I've been I was
going through a lot basically my whole
life since my mom passed away like I
wasn't listening to the men of my family
like my father was barely in my life
like that he was in and out I'm not
really having contact with him at this
moment like we talked but it doesn't go
good with our conversation also I end up
getting pregnant as well so I have a
one-year-old named Ezekiel and now my
father is trying to come back in my life
but it's like and tell me how to raise
my son but I'm just like it's not yeah
like no respect for him at this moment
so you're you're working the street down
and I figure out yes I am
I started there when I was seven
eighteen years also I'm 22 now
I played yeah the fake I west and yes
yeah do you you work with a pamper on
your own no I'm a my own then your yeah
and so tell me about that extend me is
it is that it can be but it when you
know you get approached by another you
know guy but you know it's it's a lesson
learned it's like the only way at this
moment so you know take care of me and
my son yeah and there's a lot of girls
that are doing this all right yeah I'm
not the only one this this over probably
a thousand girls out there right now and
there's are really a lot um you know
some it's just been crazy out there
lately you know it's been girls getting
chased
I've got chased multiple times out there
by like another pimp or like yeah just
weird people yeah and everything's
illegal so it's like it like on both
sides but what that is the cops just
don't want to see you in the middle of
the street like if you're on the
sidewalk that's fine but they just don't
want to see in the middle of street or
walking up to a car yeah so the cops
tend to leave you alone a little bit
yeah yeah and how many how many
customers will you pick up in a day and
a night it depends on if it's slow or
like busy but when it's slow would be
like least one two or three a day
sometimes four but if it's really really
busy it's up to like I'll say the
highest i had was like eight to nine
dates
yeah it's it's crazy would you say it's
crazy really crazy
I'll bet and what do you charge for your
services the lowest I do is 60 but the
highest is like 80 to 100 and you know
150 250 yes yeah and you're having sex
you're doing everything sometimes yeah
sometimes I do with them sometimes you
know they just want to sit down and talk
or like I had a lot of them who just ran
out their whole life story to me and
about their why do I talk to her
yeah I I go I get picked out out of a
whole lot of girls on the street it'd be
so funny but yeah most of them I mostly
talked to them I don't really just doing
anything with them so that's like easy
money using money yeah yeah I should
charge for that oh that's what I'm doing
so so your child who takes care of your
your let's see right now it's between my
sister and TV but you kind of switch my
lives with you know his phase where when
you're working yeah he's like in a
daycare and then like from there they
pick him up they choose who's mom I mean
have you been arrested I have uh whom I
take up a weeks ago I got set up by a
set up by a girl down there I guess she
was like an undercover but she was also
like on the blade as well so it's kind
of you know upsetting but I have to go
thoroughly yeah when you were a young
girl did you have dreams of a different
life for yourself I did I had a dream
like I really I generally like getting
married and like moving out of state
like I like this big old you know dream
of like moving to Hawaii and doing all
this but it didn't go as planned growing
up my whole life was just a living hell
I just say that you get depressed
sometimes I do a lot and like I break
down most of the time I'm not gonna lie
I'm a crybaby I'm a crybaby but I'm
actually like mean as well I get a lot
of people so um I mean but I'm a really
big crazy you know I'm not gonna lie
like
I've been crying for like the past
couple days cuz I've been so stressed
out I'm just like like I've been not
wanting to do this I've been wanting to
stop doing this but I end up no just
like no I'm gonna just go along with it
and look like me now I'm still here
yeah we're else can you make that kind
of money that's quickly getting a job
you know five or six hundred dollars in
a night eventually perhaps you would you
would but not right away right away
I'm just like you to pay bills right now
yeah there's no sign no wait for the big
lotto to con saw no it's working on the
street
did you finish high school I did I
graduated 2016 that's what I that's what
I did do I finished high school it was
that or do four years and I was just
like no so I went through a high school
without getting in trouble my hosting in
gear and I graduated so I end up getting
a second offer probation I mean that's a
stupid question but having your dad not
in the picture and losing your mom at
such an early age almost made this
inevitable for you yeah cuz like if you
had both your parents in your lives you
probably would have lived a very
different life yeah I think I would or
if my mother was here because I mean
when what they were like best friends
like that was my best friend my right
like I can go to her for anything
so when I lost her at that moment I just
like forget everyone you know just I
just like I gave up on everything and
then I end up going down the wrong path
and this sort of led you to working on
the street all right Queen well thank
you so much for talking to me thank you
good luck with your future and your song
and everything else thank you thank you
you